are changing the game series highlights
extraordinary women who are making a
difference right now and also for future
Generations Allison jaslow is one of
those women she's making history right
now as the first openly gay leader of a
major veterans group and she's also the
first woman to lead the Iraq and
Afghanistan Veterans of America also
known as the iava she's CEO there the
group helps more than 425 000 veterans
get the resources they need for issues
like health care and education and
jaslow by the way served two tours of
Duty as an army officer in Iraq 2004 and
2007. good morning really good to see
you all as well thank you for having me
pictures of you uh you sort of two tours
in Iraq 20 years ago this week that
George W bush authorized airstrikes that
led to those two tours in Iraq when you
think back to it and we'll get to
everything else what do people need to
remember about that war
I think the most important thing is
um you know it's not just remembering
the war but making sure that we learned
all the lessons
that we should have learned from this
particular War you know when you're a
leader in combat one of the most
difficult days that you will ever have
is when you lose somebody
um
when you lose somebody you want to be
able to look at your soldiers in the
face and say that it was for
the right reasons you know or or any
reason or to be able to explain to them
what their buddy made the ultimate
sacrifice for
um I can tell you from personal
experience I struggled to give my
soldiers that answer and I want platoon
leaders of the future to be able to look
their soldiers in the eye and know very
clearly what they lost their lives for
what they got injured for and so I think
when we reflect back on the Iraq War
um we need to be very clear going
forward that we are keeping our eyes on
you know the right Mission and making
sure that we're getting into the right
Wars
after two tours in the Army do you still
recommend service to young people
absolutely I don't I don't you know I
know
um a lot of vets at this point in my
career and I don't know anybody whether
they're still serving or decided to get
out where it's not a big part of their
life
um you know I got into the army I wanted
it to be my career I've found other ways
to serve since being in the military but
as I was telling Gail earlier you know I
think though I left the Army the Army
values are still a part of me too and so
um you know the person that it shaped me
into being the leader that it shaped me
into being is something that I can't
imagine my life without and I would
recommend to anybody a military service
of any kind well you're here because
Alice and are changing the game series
where we honor badass women we certainly
put you in that category why thank you
the first oh you're welcome the first
openly gay leader of a major veterans
organization the first woman to lead the
iava yes did you feel pressure do you
feel a burden because you're called the
first Oakland game that's something that
you have shared
you know
um one of the toughest things I've had
to like experience in my life
um though I've been to combat twice was
was coming out
um was coming out more so even to myself
before even my friends and family
um so
it is difficult to put yourself out in
this way
um but I also know the extreme value to
other people and as somebody who sees
myself as a servant leader
um if I can be of service in that way as
I step into this leadership role it's
worth me pushing myself out of my
comfort zone to do it there's a
startling statistic which is an average
of 20 service members and veterans die
by suicide every day yes what changes do
you want to see when it comes to mental
health care for our service members and
our veterans
well unfortunately I don't know a vet
who doesn't know somebody who died by
Suicide wow um so the veteran suicide
crisis is continuing to be a high
priority not only for an organization
like ours but I think more broadly
speaking
you know America doesn't want to see its
best and brightest taking their own
lives
um so there's additional work that needs
to be done to decrease the stigma I
think I give a lot a huge amount of
credit to current military leaders who
are now speaking openly about their
struggles you've got men in very high
ranking positions who are talking about
how it's okay to not be okay yes um but
there are other things we need to look
at too you know men who serve in the
military
experience childhood trauma at twice the
rate of civilians and so
people who are coming in the military if
we can help them understand and unpack
and heal their their childhood trauma
they'll be at less risk of PTSD and
other trauma further you know in their
career when it comes to understanding I
just want people to know that you were
part of the group that helped Veterans
Affairs change its motto yes was to care
for him and it shifted to those who
serve yes Bravo Allison it's a big win
last week thank you very much for your
service of course an important win too
Bravo be right back Bravo you